so this is the Brody house hmm built in
1948 Francis Brody was a major art
collector of largely post-war art this
is a new thing for me
I haven't owned many worldly possessions
in many ways it's it's therapeutic
because I spend all my time dealing with
code but this was the first place where
we really made it our home I know you
are super involved in a lot of the
detail here at the art I love design
first and foremost I've always
considered myself the product designer
more than an engineer these properties
don't become available very frequently
it just so happened that we lead a
mutual friend with Ellen she was hosting
the Oscars at the time I heard one piece
of advice to me was you know don't ever
take on the renovation of a historic
property while hosting the Oscars tell
me about these pieces those are Ming
Dynasty horses that are very fertile
I've gone from being the disruptor to
being the Lord Grantham character on
Downton Abbey whose primary
responsibility is to maintain you know
to maintain this this house are you
calling yourself Lord Parker I mean it's
out is that what's happening here Lord
Lord Parker no
you know a Quincy Jones when he designed
the house really wanted to integrate
indoor and outdoor spaces so one of the
things we did when we when we bought the
property was all of this exterior space
including the fire pit and the
wraparound and the dining table none of
this actually existed those are the
feedbacks at the Playboy Mansion
what two-thirds of the property borders
to play one back you live next to the
Playboy Mansion yeah we have a tunnel
underneath that leads into the Playboy
Mansion that they don't know about oh
what's it like living next to the
Playboy Mansion
it's act it's actually completely normal
and when winter turned two we had her
birthday party at the Playboy Mansion if
you can believe it really you're also
your daughter's birthday because they
have a Playboy Mansion they have a pride
I know that sounds salacious but they
have a private Zoo with a huge number of
monkeys and exotic animals that sounds
like quite a birthday party
alright ticket think the kids loved it
yeah so my experience at the Playboy
Mansion is very wholesome